et dernier volet de cette chronique on
parle à présent de ce groupe de députés
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés impulser un parent par jean
michel fourgous ce maire d'elancourt et
qui était députée des yvelines députés
ump il nous en excuser
nous on fait le bilan cindy allez dire
ça j'en étais sûr exact âge le bilan de
ce groupe génération entreprise par jean
michel fourgous merdé l'on croit on a
produit le crédit impôt recherche avec
madame pécresse on a lié cette pme c'est
moi qui l'ait mis dans le programme de
sarkozy l'époque c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a sauvé des milliers
d'entreprises et puis vous avez
également l'assurance vie est un des
plus gros amendements sous la vème
république qui a dépassé 70 milliards
qui dormait et qui les a même promis sur
l'économie donc voilà ce groupe a déjà
appuyé le également le grand emprunt qui
sort également du groupe génération
entreprise donc c'est surtout un groupe
qui se soucie d'envoyer l'argent qui
dort ou un os qui qui spéculent sur
l'économie réelle pour créer vraiment de
la richesse pour créer vraiment de
l'emploi c'est à l'état d'urgence tout
le monde prend peur les investisseurs
ont peur les entrepreneurs ont peur les
chercheurs innovant voyez parts on peut
pas laisser se vider du du sens
entrepreneurial français il faut arrêter
cette hémorragie d'urgence c'est pour ça
que 70 députés ont décidé de se réunir
dans ce dans le cadre de ce groupe et de
le demander d'urgence une réunion une
rencontre et monsieur hollande pour lui
expliquer la dangerosité et puis lui
donner les informations que nous on a dû
l'international de l'europe de nos
acteurs économiques et à la présidence
de ce groupe de 70 députés olivier
dassault fils du célèbre chef
d'entreprise serge dassault qui est
député ump dans l'oise depuis 1988 il
nous parle des perspectives de ce groupe
comme proposition concrète c'est c'est
de supprimer cette taxe de 60% sur les
plus values comme propositions concrètes
c'est de faire une fois pour toutes une
stabilité fiscale et juridique mais pas
dans le sens le plus élevé et dans le
sens le plus pénalisant pour les
entreprises mais au contraire dans la
sauce
pouvoir investir davantage car
l'entreprise si elle fait des profits
c'est pour les réinvestir et puis aussi
comme proposition importante c'est de
soutenir nos entreprises dans le
développement de leurs crédits